when Padme and Poe Dameron have better
chemistry than Padme Anakin beating a
dead horse on that why is that a funny
[Music]
annihilation so annihilation is written
and directed by Alex garland he's the
director of ex machina in this movie
Natalie Portman is a biologist who goes
on this expedition to this place all
right how to describe this place it's a
zone that spreading and this zone as a
shimmer to it is very enigmatic in there
so her and a crew have to go in there
and get to this destination
hopefully accrue some data hopefully
find out what the heck is going on I'm
gonna talk about what I like this movie
people who like this movie people who
hate this movie they're all gonna say
this thing they're all gonna have this
in common the movie looked fantastic
this place beautiful to look at like
this weird hybrid where Heaven and Hell
came together but one thing in
particular I was like that's horrific
there's kind of beautiful and I'm a
messed-up person probably but again
reviews are gonna have that in common
you're gonna hear a lot of the same
phrases which are the movie swings for
the fences the movie is bold it's
outside the box so really those don't
denote success it just means attempts
you can swing for the fences and strike
out it's just a reality the situation I
mean I got what the movie is trying to
say on paper I loved all of it if you
break down all the events on paper I'd
be like yeah that's great the director
of ex machina I'm going day one but
really in this movie's attempt to be a
modern art thinking piece the cohesive
film element and aspect of it got left
behind this crew of people that go out
there you're attached to a couple of
them you look at the crew of I know it's
a different movie but aliens or even
alien I'm attached to most people among
the crews in those movies here I was
attached to the concept this movie does
ask really profound questions about
biology psychology consciousness what is
life the term annihilation itself they
raised a great point if you follow my
channel for any amount of time I imagine
you have grasped by now that if a movie
looks great if the movie looks beautiful
it's not enough for me to say yeah it's
a good movie it's really you can google
anything go online Google Images you can
find yourself some pretty pictures there
you don't have to pay $15 a ticket to
see it because really this movie was a
drag in the most beautiful place
possible movie was dragging on it was
long it was slow
I was thinking okay maybe it's like the
sixth sense if you look at the sixth
sense if you take the ending of the
sixth sense away the sixth sense is just
kind of a slow burn movie that doesn't
have a lot of payoff without the ending
I figured maybe it was gonna be like the
sixth sense maybe it's a slow burn movie
sure but at the end it's all gonna come
together I'm gonna walk out of there
with my mind blowing me alive guys
I know slow burn for sure best movie of
the year so far for two months in
whatever and really the ending didn't do
it for me there's actually a thing that
happens in the ending and it goes on for
so long I was like we get it dude move
on and I do feel this movie has some
loose threads not moments that are open
to interpretation so you can think about
it for weeks on end but genuine loose
threads I feel like if a movie does that
it tries to be a modern art thinking
pace if it succeeds then the loose
threads are there intentionally if it
doesn't succeed then the loose threads
are just plot holes in the movie for me
felt like plot holes I don't want to
discourage anyone for going for a high
art thinking peace with their film it
should be encouraged I do encourage it
I'd like to see it more in movies but in
that area you really have to succeed you
really do have to stick that landing
like if a movie's going for a great fun
popcorn picture and you only end up
being a good fun popcorn picture it's
still a fun popcorn picture if the movie
goes for being a high art thinking pace
it either is that or it's not and if
it's not you run the high risk of your
film feeling very indulgent indulgent
was the word like after a screening
there are people with notepads like so
what'd you think I was like in a word
indulgent is the word I would use to
describe this movie best I can say it is
like this if you enjoy a deep concept
and you're more impressed with what the
filmmaker was trying to do rather than
what he's succeeded in doing I think
you'll enjoy it
if you require a movie to stick the
landing a my opinion didn't do it I'm
not gonna necessarily forget this movie
but I do think it might be a better time
if you're something I'll say drunk yeah
now it's a party it's not all substances
are legal in all states
alright so annihilation not the mortal
kombat lung because that's just
all-around terrible have you seen it
what did you think about it or what's a
movie that's your cerebral film your
deep thinking movie that hits you to
your core makes your question life
itself whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]